(light music)
- In my classroom, I always
ask them, who are you.
They know to respond, "I am
the leader of the world."
And it's true, they are the future.
(light music)
The importance of
teachers is unquantifiable
for this excess of students
because we do not just teach,
but we really care about our students.
(light music)
We're also their mentors,
we're also their friends.
(light music)
Every teacher uses different tools
to be an effective teacher.
One of those tools that I choose to use
because I believe the curriculum,
the rigor in it is Khan Academy.
So, it gives me immediate feedback
of okay, this person understands,
or this person doesn't.
Every student, every child, every life
has a possibility to create something.
Everyone deserves access
to free, quality education.
Then we can really see the
power of education blossom.